Yeah,
one of the fundamental thesis of this
course is that
in modern literature and the literature
that isn't so modern,
there's the notion of a human created
monster Frankenstein,
right springs to mind and at an adequate
time.
I mean Frankenstein was a fantasy and
unconscious fantasy,
a dream in actuality about the potential
dangers of unbridled technological
advancement.
Right?
Well,
this Frankenstein a monster's face,
so daily.
I mean it's become a constant part of
our existence.
Why is that?
Well,
maybe it's something like this and this
is certainly a notion that young would
agree with,
okay,
if we don't develop a moral sense as
conscious and is elaborated as our
technological sense,
the fact that we're capable of becoming
increasingly powerful will necessarily
do us in
the bigger your weapons,
the smarter you better be to control
them and so maybe it is something like
this maybe,
and this is a strict union notion.
Maybe 500 years ago when we started to
ratchet up the rate at which we were
developing our technological expertise
and left our mythological and religious
presuppositions and conceptions behind
as archaic and perhaps as predicated on
superstition.
Maybe we need to spend as much time
updating them and bringing them into the
domain of clear consciousness and
control as we have spent on developing
our technological sense.
If you were a medieval Christian or an
archaic religious thinker of any sort,
you're first presupposition was that the
world and the cosmos existed exactly as
they appeared,
which with you or at least your village
or town or country out the center and
certainly with the Earth at the center
and with the cosmos as a shield around
the earth and with the earth itself as
the domain of man being the fundamental
attribute of the cosmos.
So this is a quotation from young and
it's when I like a lot because I think
it adequately and succinctly describes
the distinction between the way that
modern people think and the way that
people think.
If they're still ensconced within
traditional belief form.
How totally did the different.
Did the world appear to medieval man?
For him,
the Earth was eternally fixed and it
rest in the center of the universe and
circled by the course of a son that's
solicitously bestowed.
It's warm despite the fact that pre
empirical people have to deal with death
and disease on a scale that I think is
completely unknown to us.
It doesn't seem unreasonable to
presuppose that there was a certain
degree of comfort to be found in the
worldview of this sort,
right,
because it appeared at least to the
casual observer that the cosmos was
human centric and that the notion that
human purpose was in some way associated
with cosmic significance seem to be
beyond question,
at least in part because there were no
theories of reality that would compete
with that initial preconception.
Man.
We're all children of God under the
loving care of the most high who
prepared them for eternal blessedness
and all knew exactly what they should do
and how they should conduct themselves
in order to rise from a corruptible
world to an incorruptible.
Enjoy US existence.
Such a life no longer seems real to us.
Even in our dreams.
Natural sciences long ago torn this
lovely veil to shreds.
How is it that people could think that
way,
given that it was so wrong and still
survive?
Given that in large part,
we are necessary necessarily creatures
of tradition.
How is it that we can sever the ties
with the manner in which our ancestors
thought
and suffer?
No,
we'll consequences in result people
think automatically and I think for good
reasons that the march of human thought
has been unbroken progress towards
increased rationality,
increased power,
increased clarity,
but it's certainly the case that as a
consequence of sacrifice of our
religious beliefs and are full of
philosophical beliefs that problems of
meaning have become more paramount for
the modern person and then you might
ask,
well,
what exactly are the consequences of
that?
And I think initially the best
perspective to take is one that's
historical.
As we've moved away from a classical,
mystical or mythological worldview,
a number of dramatic occurrences of
unfolded,
we've become much more technologically
powerful,
right?
The application of a strict empirical
model designed to abstract out from
everyone's experiment experience those
things that are material and constant
have enabled us to produce
technological implements of extreme
power,
right?
Both for good,
at least in principle with regards to
medical advances and also for eal in
terms of our ability to control weapons
of unbelievable destructive force,
so we're more powerful hardware.
Any smarter or any wiser?
Well,
I think a casual glance at the history
of the 20th century was suggest that
perhaps we're not.
I don't think there's any indication
whatsoever,
although perhaps things have improved in
the last 15 years that an additional
consequence of our capacity to extract
ourselves from our religious modes of
thought has been a palpable increase in
wisdom or tolerance or compassion or a
palpable increase in our ability to
understand explicitly what might
constitute the basis for a suitable and
stable state.
So you might take,
for example the fact that the 20th
century has been unbelievably bloody
right.
Literally hundreds of millions of people
killed in conflicts of one form or
another.
Both external say in the course of world
war two or Vietnam and internal in the
case of Nazi Germany or the Soviet Union
or any of the vast array of countries
who've subjected they're citizens too.
Terrible internal repression in the name
of the maintenance of order.
They Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn estimated
that 60 million people died in the
Soviet Union between 19,
19 in 1959 as a consequence of internal
repression,
and his estimates were that perhaps
twice that many died during the cultural
revolution in China.
Looking back on the 20th century,
one seat,
one thing seems relatively clear,
right?
Although
humanity as a whole has ceased or had
ceased at least to engage in large scale
religious conflicts.
Although they seem to have been making a
vicious comeback in the last five years.
Our ability to live together still seems
incredibly compromised by our capacity
to engage in ideological conflict.
Right?
And it doesn't seem to me ridiculous to
presume
that the battles between capitalism and
communism say,
or between capitalism and Communism and
fascism or even the emergent struggle
between fundamentalist Islam and the
West can necessarily be regarded as
anything but extensions of our tendency
towards religious and mythological
conflict.
Even though in principle systems like
Communism and fascism were not
predicated on explicitly religious
presuppositions.
Well,
it seems to me that the logical
conclusion from observations of that
sword is that even if you eradicate the
traditional trappings of a mythological
worldview,
which seems to be what's happened as a
consequence of our rise in empirical
knowledge,
that you don't eradicate the tendency
for people to formulate groups,
belief systems
around conceptions of ways that you
should behave that are at the very least
religious instructor and action,
even if they're not religious and name.
I mean,
I think it's a very peculiar
coincidence.
For example,
that the Soviet communists erected a
male Trinity Marx,
Lenin and Stalin as an apparent
replacement for the masculine trinity
that comprised the essential duties of
Orthodox Russian Orthodox Christianity.
Why would these forms reemerged so
spontaneously and what does it mean that
people who regard themselves as
essentially modern and empirical in
their presuppositions seem to be
absolutely susceptible in their
fundament to ideological claims?
I'll let you look at the Soviet Union,
which I think is very instructive case
because the Soviets,
the Russians who really the last
European power to fall prey to the
conflict between empiricism and science
and religion,
and they didn't really fall prey to that
until the mid 18 hundreds because Russia
was a relatively close society,
relatively illiterate,
uh,
maintaining a medieval structure far
past the time when other European
countries had abandoned that in the 18
fifties,
a wave of atheism spread across Russia
in some sense as a wave of
enlightenment,
but also as a plague and figures as
towering as tolstoy
remembered in his memoirs.
The very day that he realized that the
empirical discoveries of western
Europeans had eradicated his ability to
believe in the Russian Orthodox system.
You lose something like that.
What happens?
Well,
if you believe that mythological
thinking is nothing but superstitious
empiricism and that it's been replaced
entirely by a more appropriate modern
view,
then nothing happens,
right?
It's all to your benefit to become
enlightened.
But if you believe that there's more to
the story than that and that more
traditional ethical and moral systems
predicated on mythological
presuppositions are for you a map of how
to behave and what to think and how to
regulate your emotions and what to
strive for,
none of which can be replaced by a
scientific perspective.
And the eradication of a system like
that leaves a vacuum.
And then the question is,
what rushes in to fill a vacuum?
Well,
if you look at the case of the Soviet
Union seems quite instructive,
doesn't it?
I mean there's a 30 year period where
there's tremendous intellectual clash,
say between a materialist and empirical
perspective.
And in Russian Orthodox perspective,
the Russian Orthodox perspective loses
its attractiveness for the reigning
intellectual elite and the
presuppositions of communism which
appear rational by contrast,
which by all evidence we're not rushing
to fill the gap.
And I want to read you something that
nature wrote.
It's perhaps the most famous thing he
ever said.
Although it's almost entirely taken out
of context and misquoted,
and if not,
ms dot quartered,
at least misunderstood.
Because nature was one of these strange
people who was capable of living 50 or
even 100 years into the future,
and although he was,
is generally regarded as an enemy of
Christianity and superstition and was
certainly an unbelievably outspoken
opponent of Christian traditionalism,
he also knew that if you let the old
gods die,
the probability that blood would flood
the land was virtually 100 percent.
So let me read you what he wrote.
Have you not heard of that?
Mad Man who lit a lantern in the bright
morning hours,
ran to the market place and cried
incessantly.
I seek God as many of those who do not
believe in God were standing around just
then he provoked.
Must much laughter.
Why did he get lost?
Said one.
Did he lose his way like a child said
another or is he hiding?
Is he afraid of us?
Because he'd gone on a voyage or
immigrated that's the yelled and
laughed.
The Madman jumped into their midst and
pierced them with his glances.
Where there is God,
he cried.
I shall tell you,
we have killed him.
You and I,
all of us are as murderers,
but how have we done this?
How are we able to drink up the sea?
Who gave us the sponge to wipe away the
entire horizon?
What did we do when we unchained this
earth from its sun weather?
Is it moving now?
Whether are we moving now way from all
sons?
Are we not plunging continuously
backwards,
sideward,
forward in all directions?
Is there any opera down left?
Are we not straying as though through an
infinite nothing?
Do we not feel the breath of empty
space?
Has it not become colder,
is not night and more night coming on
all the while?
Must not lanterns be lit in the morning.
Do we not hear anything yet of the noise
of the grave diggers who are burying
God?
Do we not smell anything yet of God's
decomposition?
God's to decompose.
God is dead.
God remains dead.
We have killed him.
How shall we?
The murderer of all murderers,
comfort ourselves?
What was holiest and most powerful of
all that the world has yet owned has
bled to death under our knives who will
wipe this blood office?
What water is there for us to clean
ourselves?
What festivals of Atonement,
what sacred game show we have to invent
is not the greatness of this deed too
great for us,
must we not ourselves become God simply
to seem worthy of it
allows you can tell.
That's a much different notion from the
casual God is dead quotation that's most
generally associated with nature.
What?
What is he saying?
What he's saying?
Something like this.
A system like Christianity or any system
that's Qa,
that's oriented,
this society for thousands and thousands
of years,
can't simply be be eradicated by a
casual gesture without consequences and
suing and its aftermath.
What consequences will need?
She says,
well,
we'll no longer know up from down.
What does he mean by that
metaphorically?
Well App.
That's where you're headed,
right and down.
That's what you want to stay away from,
and when you eradicate the most
fundamental presuppositions of your
system,
of values,
then there is no up and there is no down
and then where are you?
Precisely.
Well,
it's not so easy.
It's not so easy to say having not
necessarily ever been in that position.
What is your life like when you don't
know up from down?
Is it merely neutral is merely no value
left or could it possibly be the case
that if up and down and both being
eradicated,
that the place that you're left and is
something much more akin to a permanent
state of suffering because maybe it's
only the case that the constant capacity
to drive for up in being enough that you
believe in the constant striving for up
is actually what makes your life
bearable to you,
and if you lost the sense of up and
down,
the place that you would end up would be
not so much neutral as terrible.
Now,
if you have any belief system at all,
you do this,
so let's say you're an advocate of
leftwing politics.
You take a pro environmental stance or
an anti corporate stance,
which is a relatively common thing to do
and long undergraduates.
What do you do when you hold that belief
system?
You view the world as it lays itself out
and you explained the manner in which it
manifests itself in terms of the axioms
of that belief system,
and you may know that you can do it
right,
you can tell a credible story about why
the world is the way it is by adopting,
say,
an anti corporate perspective because
there are all sorts of terrible things
about the world that are a consequence
say of corporate maneuvering,
and you might also say that and Piaget
would say this,
that it's a necessary developmental
stage to acquire allegiance to a given
belief system.
Why?
Well,
any APP is better than none.
That might be the first observation,
so even if your belief system is
relatively insufficient and easily
challenged on intellectual grounds and
perhaps not very complete anyways,
the fact that it does lay out a moral
structure for you and tell you good from
evil and right from wrong,
that's a.
that's a plus.
That's an advantage.
Now it's relative intellectual weakness
and it's incoherence.
Assuming it is incoherent to some
degree,
that's a flaw,
but that doesn't mean that the effort to
establish a system like that is
worthless.
It's worthwhile and need just said,
say with regards to Christianity and
Europe,
he said,
well,
the errors,
intellectual and moral of Institutional
Christianity are essentially beyond
count,
but there's one thing you have to
remember.
First of all,
in ordering of that sword is necessary
because the alternative which is always
hidden from you in so far as you're
inside a moral system,
the alternative as far worse chaos
that's worse.
I mean part of the reason that the
Germans preferred Hitler to chaos was
because they felt that the order that
Hitler promised repressive as it was was
preferable to the chaos that was likely
to ensue in its absence.
What is it about chaos that's so
terrifying?
Second Nature said,
adopting a belief system of any sort and
imposing coherency on the world,
viewing it through the lens of that
explicit system
disciplines your mind,
so for example,
to live in the absence of any stated
beliefs is hardly to live at all.
To live in the presence of a narrow
minded and extreme belief system is at
least to undergo the rigors,
both behavioral and intellectual of
coming to terms with the world from some
perspective.
Nisha said the reason that the modern
mind such as it is,
was able to free itself from the past at
all,
was because it had first thoroughly
subjected itself to the tyranny that was
imposed by the past in consequence,
disciplined itself developed enough
discipline as a consequence of that
subordination to then break free of it.
In all the science of morals so far,
one thing was lacking strange as it may
sound,
the problem of morality itself.
What was lacking was any suspicion that
there was something problematic here.
Every society,
every functioning individual,
every functioning family,
every social unit has a moral code,
but they differ.
So what does that mean exactly?
Well,
it's complicated,
isn't it?
Because the fact of the university,
a lot of the code,
the fact of the code indicates that the
code or code is necessary.
By the same token,
the fact that there's a multiplicity of
codes seems to suggest that the
particulars of a given aren't
necessarily relevant,
and so niches says brilliantly,
I think we're faced with a problem.
No life without morality,
no absolute morality.
What do we do?
What are the things young observed was
that if you look at the structure of
stories,
you thought first there is a
relationship between stories and moral
codes.
Well,
seems relatively straightforward,
doesn't it?
If you tell a simple story like a
parable,
sometimes they're complex to like an
aesop fable safe.
What do you extract out from the story?
Moral?
What's the moral?
What's the implication of the story for
behavior?
Right?
So you tell a little story about someone
who acts out of given moral code and
that person does better or worse,
and the moral of the story is if you act
in this manner,
you will do better or worse,
proverbial knowledge.
We all tell stories.
They have identifiable structure.
You can tell that because it's a movie
studio in Hollywood can produce a movie
and people all over the world will watch
it.
People all over the world,
all over the world tell stories to one
another.
The plot elements seem similar.
Morals,
similar.
That's a more difficult question,
right?
We know that the details of morality can
vary from culture to culture.
Is there anything that doesn't vary from
culture to culture?
How?
Why would you want to find that?
Hold on.
We'll xander knits and thought that one
of the most important occurrences of the
20th century
or the Nuremberg trials,
the Nuremberg trials,
brought the perpetual perpetrators of
the Nazi genocide to justice and it's
easy to be cynical about that and
perhaps you shouldn't be cynical about
it because the victors brought the
losers to trial,
and so of course the losers.
We're going to be tried from the
perspective of the winters moral code,
but Solzhenitsyn says,
well,
wait,
you know,
there's something more to this story.
At least there seems to be in that many
of the events that characterized the
Nazi atrocities were so awful outside of
intellectual argumentation because you
can provide an intellectual argument for
anything.
They were so awful.
The proper visceral embodied response of
any observer,
regardless of specific moral code,
should be repugnant,
period,
such that encoded,
at least initially in international law,
genocide is a crime against humanity,
right?
No matter what the particulars of your
moral code so goes the logic.
You cannot construct a viable moral code
that enables genocide if not a logical
impossibility.
And and I think it is a logical
It's an ethical impossibility.
And then you have to ask yourself,
and this is not precisely an
intellectual question,
does that seem credible to you?
Does it seem credible that there are
acts that are so terrible that no one,
regardless of their stated position,
should ever engage in them,
and if the answer is yes,
then I would say,
well,
if you haven't moved towards personal
except of acceptance of an ultimate up
so to speak,
you've certainly identified at least one
down that you don't want to approach.
And that's the beginnings of the
establishment of some notion of absolute
moral authority.
So what if we said hypothetically
something like this.
Let's say that morality isn't a
philosophy.
It's not something explicit,
something implicit.
How does it evolve?
Well,
emotional creatures produce it.
You don't have to produce it in
isolation.
If you were wearing a social animal,
if you live a solitary and nocturnal
existence by yourself,
there's no need for morality because you
don't have to regulate your behavior
with regards to your peers,
but your social animals,
so you're stuck with everybody else,
but everybody else could be conceived of
as a grand average,
right?
How would you act towards the average
person?
Well,
I would say that very,
very stable moral systems tell you
exactly that and they say things like a
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you.
Right?
Basic principle of reciprocity.
Why does that work?
And it's a complex precept.
It means I should treat you like I would
like to be treated by you,
and you might think,
well,
that means to be nice to you,
but that isn't really what it means
because nice isn't enough,
right?
What I want from you really is
communication,
real communication feedback.
What am I doing that's acceptable and
good?
What am I doing that's unacceptable and
not good?
And that latter aspect of feedback as
part of the reason why,
if you're a psychopathological and
isolated,
you're in much worse shape because half
of your sanity or three quarters of it
or 90 percent of it,
who knows is distributed sanity.
You don't have to be that sane as long
as you're hanging around other people
because as soon as you do something
that's deviant,
they're going to raise an eyebrow at
you.
Right?
And then you think,
oh,
well not that.
And as soon as you do something good,
then they're going to pay more attention
to you and smile at you.
So all of the information about how to
regulate yourself is out there in the
world,
right?
The average person.
How many people do you interact with in
a week?
300.
Say maybe it's not that many.
100.
How about year thousand?
2,000.
Five thousand,
10,000.
What do they all telling you?
Well,
the message is similar across people.
How similar.
Don't know exactly how similar that
would stories tell you.